[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
while we're on vacation
michael rosenberger sports illustrated
senior writer
profiled trevor lawrence the unrivaled
arrival of trevor lawrence and all of a
sudden there were some quotes
pulled from that questioning how much he
loved football
and awards and all of that while trevor
lawrence was getting married this
weekend so michael rosenberg kind enough
to join us
michael uh preconceived feelings ideas
notions about trevor lawrence were what
going into that profile
basically just that he was really good
at football you know i i was looking
and there were bits and pieces but yeah
he's still so young i didn't feel like i
really knew him and and at some point
uh in the course of reporting and i
don't even remember where it started i
started to get this sense that he was
just kind of wired a little different
and it was one of the first questions i
asked him and he's like oh yeah i don't
have that chip on my shoulder
and having been around the nfl for a
long time i walked out of there going is
this guy really going to be the first
pick but
but but yeah that's just who he is and i
brought this up to louis riddick last
hour i said you know
it's not a coincidence they're
quarterbacks who love having that chip
on their shoulder that they'll carry it
with them
their entire careers the last
quarterback i remember
who didn't have a chip on his shoulder
felt like it was andrew luck
and andrew luck checked out at age 29
decided he was not going to play anymore
so i i don't know if there's a there
there
but i do think that it caught my
attention
that he said it you might think it but
it's another thing to say it michael
it is and and i kind of went through it
with trevor i was like
because i said people can take this the
wrong way and he said yeah i know
oh so about that he knew he knew that
that would cut i don't know if he knew
the level of it
um so you warned him in the moment
i did and after i just said this is what
it is and yeah and it's in the story
like he knows this is going to be
twisted because
i think that says something about him
too that kind of reinforces how he is
that
he knew that there would be some
blowback and he wasn't worried about
that either you know he's not trying to
shape the image he's pretty comfortable
with
who he is so i found that very endearing
what that means for him in the long term
i guess we'll see
how much time did you spend with him i
had about an
hour plus the photo shoot and video
shoot and then a few questions
afterwards
anything stand out aside from those
quotes
you know i i think what i took away from
it as much as anything was
he's very smart he's he's very
comfortable himself and he's very
comfortable questioning things you know
he
he has such sort of a simple image of
this guy who was just
number one recruit number one pick
marrying his high school girlfriend very
religious
uh and he's a lot deeper and more
thoughtful and
and more inquisitive i think than than
maybe has been out there and
and between he and marissa the dynamic
there you really got the sense these are
kind of two equal partners it's not just
it's not just the quarterback and his
pretty high school girlfriend i mean
these are life partners so
uh there's a lot of depth there uh it's
kind of funny to me that this is all
blown up because i feel like anybody
questioning him right now if they spend
10 minutes with them would walk away and
be like what a great guy i'd love to
have that guy in my team so
i don't think the jaguars should be all
that concerned but but that was just my
take
but you know how it works though michael
this
you know time of the year leading up to
the draft he's been spotless
i mean nobody's critiqued him we we just
sort of said well that's trevor lawrence
he's in a different category
now you can bring trevor lawrence back
into mainstream
you know sports world and i think it was
the timing of it more than anything else
but also that what that what stood out
to me was when you talked about him
getting married at such a young age and
that there were probably people who were
critical of that
going into this profession yeah and he
said that too he's like people say and
as
people say what are you doing getting
married i'm like they just come up and
say that
to you and he's like yeah he kind of
can't believe it himself it's pretty
rude but he's like what am i going to do
i'm not going to wait i know who i want
to marry and i'm going to get married
so uh there is a confidence there that
that's not
it's not brash you know it's not that
johnny manziel thing it's not the the
baker mayfield you know i woke up
feeling dangerous it's just
and he knows how good he is too you know
did you interview manziel uh i have not
i never interviewed johnny manziel i was
waiting for him to reach his second year
as a starter
it's weird how if you said hey your
daughter is bringing home
this person not this is what he does for
a living
this person he would probably check all
the boxes here
but it feels like in today's world you
know we're like
i don't know i'm a little skeptical here
yeah well it's true and and and
if you think of all the reasons guys
fail you know
marrying young and wanting to be with
that person is not usually very high in
the list so
uh it is different but um i i guess
my take away from it like this is there
a danger that
that he gets beaten up and retires like
andrew luck did early
sure would the cults you know do they
regret taking a
phenomenal quarterback no i mean i i
think there's risk with every single guy
in the draft
i think trevor lawrence's risk is
different from most but still
smaller than just about everybody else
have you followed up with him
since the quote-unquote controversy
uh i have not i mean he did get married
uh i will do that with the family this
week
and and nobody has said anything
negative about the story even when he
tweeted this weekend it was some people
are misreading my comments you know he
had initially
for whatever it's worth shared the story
on social media before it blew up so i
i don't know what they think i can't
speak for them are we taking anything
out of context
i'm sure you're not dan but uh i think
i mean a little bit i've seen i've seen
i've seen the poll quotes of you know
he doesn't need the super bowl to be
happy and of course people jump on that
if you read the story
it's different i mean there's never been
a question about this guy's work ethic
you know he
and this is i guess the best way i could
sum it up he doesn't go to
when he lose the game it doesn't keep
him up at night but wanting to win does
get him up in the morning
so that's different i mean that's
different from tom brady and peyton
manning and drew brees and all these
guys
but as long as he gets up in the morning
wanting to win those games and wanting
to go to the facility and wanting to
watch film and
and wanting to play through injuries and
and everything that's required of an nfl
quarterback as long as he does that
uh who really cares if he if he goes
home and starts smashing things when he
lose the game you're forever intertwined
with trevor
lawrence because these quotes uh good or
bad
are gonna stand out ten years from now
when i have you on and go michael can
you believe we made a big deal over this
or
hey michael we were on onto something i
i might be forever intertwined with him
but i don't think he's ever interfering
with me
uh great job michael great to talk to
you again and thanks for joining us
always a pleasure thanks so much that's
michael rosenberg sports illustrated
senior writer